ciao a tutti vi starete stare dentro
vita e oggi andiamo a vedere e tagliare
e video dei transformers e in un timido
influito animals xx fermo stress che
sono usciti ora in edicola che potete
trovare in allegato al magazine
ufficiale a vivere in grande tra l'altro
allora questi switch sono i più grandi
qui si offre sforzi come successe con i
più grandi che abbia mai scritto
precisiamo vedere tutti assieme
seleziono pari ma la punta ancora più
bella di valore e poi guardate un po per
un po quando li fissate dentro ci sono
delle palline colorate galline colorate
su prescrizione comunque sono superati 3
3 più grandi che abbia mai avuto e che
abbia mai visto sono veramente
fantastici e poi ognuno ha un nome
quindi prima andiamo a vederli tutti
assieme e poi andiamo a tagliarli a
finire tutto è trasparente che vi tutte
le palline colorate di milano
nei commenti si potete scrivere qual è
il vostro preferito che non vi diremo
quale il nostro preferito allora io
l'aran gorilla perché pratica è un
arancio però è anche un gorilla vedete
c'è anche lo sarà neanche la codino che
dietro i colori arancio gorilla poi fra
doloroso fragola più orso potesse mai o
mai più
s.anna miglio sembra un po ad anita
analisi ananas più coniglio per gatta
una vera più una gatta e il cocco ragno
ragno quindi sono troppo the pin di
questo lo sanno vedere la run gorilla
candore mostriamo fa con abbiamo lana
video che youtube cannonero analizza con
in bacheca
queste sono le orecchie e questa è la
parte di sopra dell'anas sono fatti
veramente super bene cari
ero troppo presto st diana ea le palline
gialle che bello io devono costituirsi
abbiamo il coraggio andiamo ad aprirlo
mediamente gigante pronostico è una noce
di cocco con le zampine quindi che
sembra un ragnetto toto terrore marino
fissavo lo senti rumori fater morisse mr
ci sono i prof belli ea questo le
pallini tipo crystal trasparenti crystal
ed è il coraggio di poco conto e spesso
comino a mo di fragola allora guardiamo
le palline rosa o rosso bellissimo ed è
un orsetto quale orecchiette le zampe
era volte dietro alla codino questo
squisito luzione rischi per gatta quindi
spero k
ma che bello come un vecchietto
erogatori chieti appunto dal gatto
poi la cosine dell'ampera e qui dietro
ma così miracolo di gatto belli da
strisciare superarsi st mesto
wow qui però perché se uno pensa di
aprire numerone orbis in tantissime
allora la faccia e qua e qua c'è la cody
le del pese anche vero che sono le
foglie dell'uva sembra un piccone enorme
d'uva chi con una charango rino è cotto
ragno qua il magazine quindi potete
prendervi mi dicono il magazine con in
allegato un flute ei muri a 999 quale
l'opera perché comunque sono el horr
dice io non ho mai visto degli squisiti
così grandi e sono profumatissimi
fantastici comunque andiamo a vedere il
magazine
vediamo un po cosa sia interessante qua
ci sono tutti qui si con i loro nomi per
cifrare le bustine del tè l'angolo della
geografia enigmistica curiosità delle
piazze più belle d'italia città fantasma
i luoghi più inquietanti e misteriosi
del mondo interessante questo qui questo
è il magg
il signor nostro preferito prima e poi
nei commenti qual è il vostro preferito
tra questi numeri da fare ancora non li
ho visti di tutti è che hanno profumando
bene tutta la mensa che voluto scelto e
quale è il sole il mio è quello di gina
valore si perché tutta loro guardate
come giorni nei quali richiede la
codeina io preferisco il coraggio perché
sono un ragno perché sono un cocco i
commenti qual è il vostro preferito che
così fa con il nostro slime trasparente
allora iniziamo con per le tifo per te
mi dispiace tagliarli perché sono
bellissimi possono anche super curiosa
se di auto molto spessi
che belle ce ne sono tantissime dentro
ma guardate quanto sono tantissime e
palline viola
ed ecco qua come rimasto lo stesso in
realtà siccome il taglietto l'ho fatto
piccolino si può riempire di slime o di
farina qualsiasi cosa si può arricchire
mutuamente rimasta anche la forma
dell'upi ora non posso perdere comunque
vecchissimi queste palline aprire la
tentazione un altro un coraggio
vediamo di che colore sono tanto in
tanto guarda apriamo un po di più
queste sono crystal trasparentissime né
volata qualcuno anche qua è tra le altre
falli l'uva bellissimo e morgex stila
modo destro rilassante poi vedremo come
diventa con fly si stanno già emergendo
nello slime trasparente non so se si
vede ma si stanno già immergendo in
profondità
chissà come diventerà dopo con tutti i
colori
ora prossimo andiamo ad aprire la pelle
gatta appena gatta che troppo carina è
una delle mie preferite perché adoro i
gatti era troppo carina un prof un
fantastico ft a poste le palline sono 24
ognuno sembra così celesti ma forse è
l'effetto delle palline sotto che bello
se già un mix di colori che bello wow
sono tantissime mischia vole come
superina stron te mister simoni dentro
ora abbiamo viola verde e trasparente
chissà come sarà lo slang dopo allora
prossimo run gorilla il primo che
abbiamo visto
vediamo un po sono arancioni che bene
offre a un po di più ecco qua non mi
devo dirti la mischia del sole
i colori arcobaleno per la fonte
andiamo ad aprire ora la na li ion
l'ananas e coniglio che a questo
vecchietto con i visto vediamo fra
giallo dentro o trasparente cielo che ma
bellissime queste palline gialle qua
[Musica]
gigante enorme tutto arcobaleno che
bello super rilassante mettere le mani
con dentro dopo di provare anche tu
vitale tavolo il mio preferito mi
dispiace un po aprirlo però voglio
vedere come sono le palline dentro
vediamo sono rosso rosa amoroso
che bello
oddio ha riempito su tela vaschetto meno
vuole preso una vaschetta grande wow
sono tanti rilassante sentite di studi
anche allora andiamo a mischiare il
tutto con lo slime 20 contro il
rilassante immersi la mantengono
bello rilassa guardate che bello oltre
ci sono tutti i colori l'eures viola
stanno entrando dentro lo slime
trasparente vedete un po bello non vi
fottono sulla versione del fantastico si
sta mischia tutto queste palline che
sono di fatto si sentite che suoni smr
fantastici
è soppressa ma da questo sì
[Musica]
mazza
bellissimo articolo vediamo sotto
guarda che appello a rate come stiano
ancora un pochino e poi siamo pronti per
toglierlo dalla ciotola maestro band
oltre sony super smr allora ecco cosa in
quasi pronte per capovolgerlo vedere
com'è congresso per rimontante quasi
soli fantastiche e giganti come potete
vedere poi tutte le palline di colore al
capolinea
siamo pronti a capovolgerlo si giocherà
tra tre ore
ok pronti per capovolgerla pronti 32
tutti io cosa tantissimo ho fatti io non
ce la faccio
eccola
come sempre grande possono cadere tutto
nuovo per curate quant'è grande ragazzi
e incredibile grande è diventato il
primo molto time ha preferito questa
fantastica e corapi tutti i colori tutti
i colori g orbi qualche pallone è fatta
lei era brava un pop e morbidissimo
neanche piccolo piccolo è bello lo slang
trasparente
no grazie potete trovare qui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
stato proprio non ammette di non ama
giocare con i tre strumentisti
mousseline ciao